what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
counting down the top 10 strongest
characters in all of demon slayer if you
like seeing demon slayer on this channel
make sure to smash that like button to
let me know if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and ring that notification
bell so you actually get notified when
you videos come out for even more demon
slayer content and crucial updates you
can follow us on twitter and instagram
at anime out drawer top-10 lists can
always fire people up so i just want to
clarify that this is my opinion given
what we know so far if you think
differently that's totally cool let me
know how you drank the characters
differently and why in the comments
obviously with this kind of list there
will be manga spoilers so you've been
warned now without further ado let's
jump into it I know this is a top 10
list but I'm going to start with a bonus
number 11 since I really want to talk
about one of my favorite characters the
character that I'm talking about is Gil
the water pillar EU is presented as
being very overpowered in the beginning
for instance he takes out Louie who was
giving tan general and Ned Zuko so much
trouble without breaking a sweat it's
actually one of my favorite flexes in
Demon Slayer after a long and
excruciating battle the ruie is about to
finish ton jutsu off and that's when gu
makes his appearance who uses his most
powerful attacks on you and you use a
water breath form that he created
himself in order to render ruies attacks
completely useless the best part is he
does it without even moving
then with a stoic expression on his face
he swiftly cuts off through his head
before we can even react he almost looks
bored as he's killing this demon who was
just moments ago being presented as a
very strong formidable and almost
unbeatable opponent he goes on to fight
against the extremely powerful upper
moon three Icaza alongside ton zero
using teamwork they managed to survive
until akiza decides to take his own life
during this battle key you manifested
the mark that increases one speed and
power thus he is currently strong he's
ever been but he will definitely need
time to heal from those wounds and now
we get to the actual top 10 let's heat
things up with the fire pillar at number
10
as soon as arkansas sees him he can tell
that the man goku is exceptional
strong it is noteworthy that he
compliment certain Goku strength much
more than he complements gives strength
he comments that his battle spirit is
quite polished and that he's getting
close to supreme territory off cuz I was
impressed with Ren Goku's reaction speed
and source style as well he desperately
wants him to become a demon so he can
enter divine territory and avoid the
inevitable decline that comes with
growing older
tangina wants to help but he's badly
wounded not to mention he's much weaker
that held V when akiza makes his second
appearance the San Goku has to take on
this insanely powerful upper moon alone
compared to when a stronger ton shuttle
angee team up against akka and are still
overpowered then Goku fights by himself
and almost succeeds in killing him even
though he hasn't gotten the powerup
associated with the markings that demon
slayers get off cuz a cauldron Goku
strength unbelievable when he stops his
left-handed punch even Wadden Goku has
our castles right arm coming through his
stomach
then Goku is willing to sacrifice his
own life and plans to hold a castle
until the Sun comes out
however Alcazar rips his own arms off so
he can run away he flees before then
Goku is even dead and more importantly
then Goku succeeded in saving tan judo
and in escape as a result you can make
the argument that ton zero is right when
he says then Goku is the winner and
occurs as the loser I cuz I ran away
before killing his opponent and then
Goku was strong enough to protect his
weaker juniors I don't mean to say that
and Goku is stronger than Icaza because
if the Sun wasn't coming up Icaza
wouldn't have any significant issues
with finishing off and in Goku the
reason I place them above gear is
because a mark luster and Goku could
fight aqus alone long enough to protect
others and even come up with a way to
threaten all Casas life without being
killed immediately while a mark time
zero and a mark you we're having trouble
against Gaza and would have probably
lost if I cuz I didn't choose to finish
himself off then Goku also gets my
respect for staying completely calm as
he's dying
he even comfort stunts you know and
encourages him even though he's the one
dying he sheds no tears and dies with a
smile on his face very cool and Goku
very cool at number nine I'm going to
put ton zero this is a bit of a
difficult one I do
want to over-exaggerate tangelos power
since he's a relative new be compared to
the pillars he definitely has the
potential to become the strongest in the
entire series however he still has a lot
of room to grow unlike a tango coup for
instance who according to a casa had
reached the peak of his potential before
he died
thus I'll play it safe and put time zero
here below a few pillars that I'll get
into in a bit all that being said though
we also shouldn't underestimate Angelo's
current powers before GU joins the fight
against a casa he sees tangelo in action
and he looks shocked by the progress
tangelo has made he notices that tan
juno's pow'r now matches that of a
pillar keep in mind this is just the
beginning of the fight as we know tons
of strength grows rapidly and by the end
of this fight he is much stronger than
he was at the beginning he accomplished
what an goku ngu couldn't he
successfully cuts off Bacchus head and
Icaza even assumes that he might have
entered divine territory during this
battle he manages to access the
see-through world where he can see his
enemies whole body as if their flesh was
transparent he manages to clear his mind
and quell his battle spirit which I cuz
I can't attack using this ability he is
able to cut off all cos øz hand without
being detected Icaza looks at ton judo
and every single cell in his body down
to his cheek hair tells him to kill
tangelo this is something he didn't feel
when he fought against it and goku engh
you suggesting that puncher is now more
dangerous than both of them however even
after he cuts off akiza's head Icaza
doesn't die tanja is too weak to keep
fighting so it's lucky that Icaza freely
decides to end his own life when it
comes to strength it seems that ton zero
still hasn't reached a casas level but
he's always getting stronger and there's
no doubt that he'll eventually surpass
it next there's sana me the wind pillar
at 8th place there's no doubt that he's
one of the strongest pillars his
countless scars show that he has a lot
of battle experience in fact he's so
strong that before he even knew about
the demon slayer core or about knee
chilling blades he was killing demons he
armed himself with many blades and then
fought demons with them he caught them
and then tied them to a tree so that
they would burn to death when the Sun
came up despite how dangerous this was
he didn't die mainly he cites his blood
which intoxicates demons as the
Mary cause of his survival but in truth
you have to be very strong in order to
survive before he even became a hot-shit
or pillar he defeated a lower ranked Wan
demon moon with his friend another
impressive feat his friend died but the
fact that they did it without help from
a hashida
shows how strong Sena me was even then
he's only gotten stronger since then
upper demon moon one notices at one
point that simony is one of the most
durable pillars he's encountered so far
because the others would have been dead
if they had taken the same amount of
damage like you sodomy is currently a
marked pillar so that allows him to
increase his base strength even further
he trained with Gil made the strongest
pillar which speaks to his ability as
well in the fast paced battle against
demon 1/1 he can at least in the
beginning keep up with Gil may speed and
coordinate his attacks with him demon
wound one notices that even among
pillars sodomy and Gil May are highly
skilled sodomy eventually starts lagging
behind Gil may as the battle progresses
but that's only because the opponent is
so strong there's no doubt that sodomy
is definitely one of the strongest
pillars in the series number seven is mu
Ichiro the miss pillar although I was
originally thinking about placing sodomy
here I ended up having to play smoochie
go ahead of him because we have seen the
miss pillar accomplish more impressive
feats up to this point perhaps the order
will have to change as we see sana me
partake in more battles but as of now I
couldn't justify putting him ahead of
Moishe toe which have been an upper moon
on his own not only that he wrecked him
first demon moon 5 has the advantage but
then marks manifest on mu Ichiro's face
and his power shoots up demon moon 5
enters his final form which he calls
godlike he makes a whole big deal out of
how this form is unbeatable and how it's
stronger than diamonds thus it's even
funnier when mu each you know
effortlessly cuts off the demons head
before he can even react this feat is so
impressive that even the narrator has to
interrupt a story and tell us the fact
that a wounded Muccino
can manage to defeat and upper moon is a
really unnatural situation then later
he's the one who manages to sneak up on
demon 1/1 and stab him after Gil main
takes off one of the demons arms it may
have literally cost mutirão an arm and
but he was able to land a significant
hit on the strongest demon moon remember
mu Ichiro is related to demon moon one
and thus he is related to the
overpowered breath of the Sun user who
even scared Mouzon so his genes possess
the best possible potential and he too
can see the transparency through world
that Tom judo and demon moon one can see
and yo makin sense to top it all off mu
Ichiro has accomplished all this by the
age of 14 which is even younger than
tangelo he has insane potential and I
just really hope that he'll somehow
still be able to fight in the future
after the serious injuries he's received
from the current battle in 6th place is
akiza
even as a kid a Kazakh could beat up
grown man in fact when he was still
human
he killed 67 swordsmen with his bare
hands because they poison Acosta's
fiance and sensei
it was so unthinkable that a young man
could cause so much damage at the time
that many people thought it was the act
of a demon the record was so absurd and
preposterous that it was regarded as a
fictitious tale for 30 years before
being erased akasa was just an 18 year
old human at the time and he was already
this strong so you can imagine how much
stronger he got when he became a demon
then goku a strong pillar in his own
right would not have posed any threat to
akasa on his own without the Sun the Sun
coming up was Arango whose only shot at
killing Icaza but i cuz i escaped before
that could happen while Alcazar mortally
wounded and Goku Alcazar quickly
recovered from an angle whose attacks
then he fought a mark enhanced GU and a
greatly improved tangelo it is worth
noting that the lull ability that made
Ruiz attacks useless was itself useless
against our causes attacks tons you know
even got stronger over the course of the
battle and managed to cut off a casus
head even if I caused a loss at this
point it still would have been
impressive that he lasted so long since
he was outnumbered and his opponents
were very powerful themselves however
his head was about to fully regenerate
Icaza was only defeated because he chose
to die gracefully he saw there was no
point in fighting after he regained his
memories before he disappeared tonsure
tried to hit him with a sword but he was
so drained
that the sword just fell out of his
hands he was also in no shape to fight
aqus I could have had a relatively easy
victory at this point so it wasn't a
matter of strength he really only lost
because he chose to self-destruct ocula
is one of my favorite villains in anime
and by the time you watch this I should
have a video out explaining why I think
Icaza is the best villain in all a demon
slayer so I recommend you check that out
because I can't fanboy over him as much
as I'd like to in this video in fifth
place
I got demon moon to DOMA before the
fight with tangent or anger you there's
no doubt that DOMA was stronger than a
Caza that's why he had the higher
ranking after all however some people
may argue that Alcazar reached a new
level of power right before dying when
he was about to completely recover from
having his head cut off but the problem
is that Icaza didn't end up surviving
and we never saw that new power in
action so I can't really take it into
account
besides it's quite possible that DOMA
could have experienced a similar power
upgrade if his body wasn't completely
overflowing with customized demon poison
so I place Toma here even though I
recognized that one could make the case
for Alcazar being stronger we never
really got to see DOMA go all-out he
defeated Connor at the flower pillar and
Shinobu the insect pillar without much
difficulty
he was overpowering Ennis K and Cano so
bad that he was about to let some ice
clones to feed them while he peaced out
of the room
however the customized poison that was
in Chernobyl's body kicked in and
started melting his face because of this
his clothes disappeared then in order to
protect his poison self he created a
giant buddha like statue out of ice but
as Cannell points out in his rough and
clearly lacks precision in short it was
an act of desperation nowhere near as
powerful and troublesome as it would
have been if he wasn't poisoned this
giant statue seems to be one of his
strongest techniques but he waited too
long to use it it is only because of the
poison plan that Shinobu came up with
that eNOS KN can now finally succeed in
defeating DOMA so rather than assuming
that DOMA is not that powerful we should
recognize that we never even got to see
his full power thanks to the perfect
execution of shinobis ingenious revenge
plan DOMA was so overpowered before his
death
that he himself didn't even need to
fight his smaller ice clones were strong
enough to do the fighting for him and if
he wasn't so obsessed with absorbing
woman he'd still be alive effortlessly
flexing on people with that carefree
smile on his face in fourth place we had
Gil made the rock pillar we are told
that he is the strongest pillar even
before the mark appeared yo may had as
demon moon one points out developed his
body and technique to the utmost while
he's fighting Yomi and Sunnah me demon
moon wan-koo coochie bow says that both
are highly skilled even among pillars
but he singles out Yomi as being
especially powerful while sana me is
completely caught off guard by one of
Kakashi bows attacks
Yomi has time to react and uses his
chain to alter the angle of attack so
that sana me just loses some fingers
rather than his entire arms as Sammy
admits the more damage he takes the
slower he gets and the more he holds
gilma back
kyo may like tom gyro and mu each hero
can access the see-through world with
his senses and he is the one that
manages to get the first significant hit
on kakushi bow which takes off the
demons entire arm he was able to control
his own blood circulation in a way that
deceived Kakashi Bo and caught him off
guard that led to the chain of events
that allowed Mui Chiu know to stab
kakushi bow and ganya to shoot him
currently as of chapter 174 the demon
slayers seemed to have the upper hand
and there's no way they would have been
able to get to this point if not for
gilman and it's not super relevant but
now that I think about it Gil Mae would
make an epic rock type gym leader in
Pokemon
step aside Brock in 3rd place we had
demon moon Wan kakushi Bo the many eyed
breath of the Moon user is a force to be
reckoned with to be sure he's been
wrecking 3 of the strongest pillars
during the vast majority of the fight
he's completely outnumbered his
opponents are strong and if my
assumption is correct he hasn't gone
full power yet I think he still might be
holding off on using a blood demon arts
power yet he still seems to crush all of
his opponents effortlessly until yo may
finally gets a hit on him and a table
seemingly began to turn the fact remains
though that it took three of the
strongest pillars and ganya to just
temporarily stop this demons one-sided
onslaught
so it's safe to say that he's even
stronger than Gil May as of now in
second place we have the demon Godfather
himself moves on there is a reason that
moves on is a progenitor of demons and
the main antagonist in the demon Slayers
series he's so strong that's simply
giving more of his blood to another
demon will make them significantly
stronger if it doesn't kill them first
all 12 demon moons including demon moon
one worked for him and follow his orders
he's been around for approximately 1,000
years and in all that time no one has
been able to kill him no matter how many
times you cut off muslins head he'll
simply regenerate the only way to kill
him appears to be with the Sun but he's
even trying to become immune to that if
he succeeds he'll be all but invincible
so far only one person has been able to
successfully challenge him and that
brings us to the number one strongest
character in the series yo Deecee
Sookie Cooney your each she was a breath
of the Sun user he was demon moon Juan's
younger twin brother and he was the only
man we know of who came close to the
feeding moves on before moves on managed
to escape he is the infamous man with
the hanafuda earrings that Mouzon gets
PTSD ask flashbacks about at some point
your each he knew and ancestor at
Angelo's and entrusted him with the
earrings there are a lot of parallels
between tangina and your ichi
including the fact that they both wear
the earrings both have similar marks on
their foreheads and both seem to use
breath of the sun' style that is if we
assume that dance of the fire God and
the breath of the Sun are indeed
connected as has been suggested in the
series it seems like ton zero is the one
that will carry on your each she's well
and eventually gets strong enough to
kill Mouzon however for now yo Deecee
holds the number one spot even though
his brother was a strong demon and your
ichi was over 80 years old when they
fought you would eat she completely
outclassed his older brother
Kakashi bo knew he was going to be
finished off soon but luckily for him
your ichi seemed to die of old age right
before he could finish him off like a
true boss he died standing up just as
fellow epic old guy white beard did at
one piece not even death could bring him
to his knees and those are my thoughts
on a top 10 ish strongest characters in
the series to date let me know what you
think
and let me know if you would rank them
differently and why in the comments
below if you liked this video make sure
to smash that like button to let me know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
ring that notification bell so you
actually get notified when new videos
like this one come out for even more
Demon Slayer content and crucial updates
you can follow us on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar make sure to
leave suggestions for future videos
you'd like to see below a big thank you
goes out to our patrons over on patreon
who help make videos like this one
possible I especially want to thank our
pro hero tier patrons the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
King's eldress angel Cruz Steelers poet
Pablo and a troppo straight and are the
one tier patrons the ones who stand atop
all clans Stephen and Radha a lowland
autumn Maddie Mac 239 and makoto-kun
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon calm
and me up floor and becoming a patron
today for as little as one dollar if you
do so you'll get your name featured in
future videos alongside these pillars
right here and you'll even get access to
our private patron Olli discord so check
out patreon.com/crashcourse
[Music]